[Music]
foreign
the jokes are funny everything's a
little faster
there will be things probably that
mirror things that people are dealing
with in their own life it's fun and
funny we get a little dash of Hope and
it's really special I mean there's
there's really nothing like it
[Music]
the best man is beloved by so many
people and forever and ever and ever
there's been talks of doing a third film
or a series The Best Man was about
showing upwardly mobile black people in
a way that I hadn't seen on screen
before you know what you play too much I
knew I wanted to revisit these
characters and give these folks some
adult stuff to deal with it's just weird
not having something that I'm passionate
about it looks like taking the ass
whooping is your passion
being allowed to do a limited series
really gives us an opportunity to have a
full experience of where the characters
are now black Twitter has memeed you oh
no it's not that bad God no executive
producer and Coach showrunner in
partnership with Malcolm one of our
themes for the series is midlife
metamorphosis none of us are the same
people we were 20 years ago no black
woman gets to where you are without
great instincts so whatever your next
move is going to be will be the right
one we've watched these characters grow
up so we get to see them as adults we're
telling the story of these people who
have evolved together who are changing
so together we're grown man I'm getting
married and moving into the bed hold up
you said to bet what no
in this series things are different they
had to be
had some different the characters are so
rich that you feel for each one when you
watch the franchise I am feeling
something that I have not felt in a long
time those relatable elements of love
and friendship and tragedy and comedy
there's the humor and the depth the
culture craves that as one who's been to
more protests and rallies than any of
you I'm not letting y'all Off The Hook
from at least reading about the issues
don't just read the book Robin read the
room boo
audiences are going to walk away from
this feeling as though they were a part
of the show
what's up Lance I would hug you but uh
not with that on the loose oh yeah my
bad when we all came back together it
gave me a chance to relive the unity of
our friendship we're all grateful that
we've had this opportunity to be a part
of a franchise that has lasted this long
I'm not me without you and you all have
worked way more than a pace
I mean it's a really big paycheck
foreign
[Music]